you know guys the term 200 IQ is
reserved for a very special type of play
when it comes to League of Legends I'm
column for the score eSports and this
week we went back to school to give you
the top 10 200 IQ plays in the league
now for this list guys bear in mind
we're not talking about mechanical out
plays here
faker Ryu might have been legendary but
at the end of the day came down to raw
skill for this list we're looking at
those more cerebral big brain out plays
so let's get on with it with the top 10
200 IQ plays from League of Legends
starting off our list at number 10 is so
Aza's impressive play against SKT Origen
were certainly the underdogs in their
2015 World Championship semi-final match
against the Korean dynasty and needed
every edge they could get so has found
himself in a tight spot after a gank
from bangy but was able to make a
dazzling escape thanks to some
incredibly quick thinking and perfect
timing and the stun is still available
the cue comes in get some damage devil
wears his team gonna be there's no one
around right now he's still
ha
[Applause]
their first Soyuz tries to juke out both
members with his awkward flash the angle
that you would not expect him to go at
number nine we have cloud nines impact
who look to be in a tough spot after
using most of his abilities to avoid a
2v1 gank from team I'm a with only 1/3
of his health left impact managed to
flash to the safety of his turret what
happened next was proof of the Korean
top laners 200 IQ as a perfectly placed
equalizer allowed him to turn the tables
on his opponents
coming in at number eight is exiles
timely ultimate during the summer split
quarterfinals against Giants with a
comfortable lead in Game one the
unicorns of love were looking to secure
Baron but Giants had other plans and
attempted to quickly rush the Baron pit
Veritas is ash and Hillis Ang's Brom
helped keep Giants out of the pit long
enough to move to secure the Baron but
it was exiled perfectly-timed ultimate
that allowed the unicorns to escape with
their lives
stop omission sometimes don't even know
this is going on now the blue trinket
comes in but mavens would be too late
hiccup the CP outlets mini game axle is
running mana rent for a potential steal
who come in here does not happen moogle
finds it and everyone over the wall
chatzi will be the sacrificial lamb
he just allows everyone to get out alive
with the Exile I was such a good ol from
exile I was not expecting that place to
come out at all but that is such an
effective use of the horizon
making its way in at number seven is g2
sec ception 'el team play against fnatic
faced with a 3v5 situation it looked
like g2 had no way of fending off
fanatics five-man rush but Hertz managed
to turn the tides of the fight that
started with a perfectly placed miasma
to punish jezza's forward positioning
and push caps out of the front line to
get out with it many members as possible
ban against our chances goes in with the
hookshot saved for a moment or two
before the twin Fang takes him out cats
his intervention is on cooldown expected
chasing with the parlay in goes Brooks a
trucker's hitch kick reps lanterns after
safety this is for three
between perks instant flash on to
Mickey's Lantern and his last-second
heal from twin fangs and dangerous game
mastery g2 managed to walk away with two
kills only losing expect at the very end
of the fight while our number six play
may not seem like much from the outset
when dealing with genius there is always
more than meets the eye rocks had just
lost their top laner but noticed an
opening after two of freaka players
returned to the fountain and took the
chance to start the barrel spirit
attempted to get into position to steal
the baron from rocks but he had other
plans as he packed in between spirit and
the baron catching the sonic wave and
holding on to his flash for just the
right moment moving away from the baron
buff not actually being up there soul
for the resonating strike to get into
range for this if he flashes any sooner
there's a chance spirit doesn't use his
- and he later and spirit would end up
in the Baron pit in perfect position to
attempt the baron steal simply put this
200 IQ timing secured rocks the baron
the number 5 play on our list sees
phoenix ones arrow set up his team for a
successful team fight against Team
Liquid as X special locks down the enemy
Brom arrow seizes the opportunity to hit
multiple carries dodging everything Team
Liquid throws at him before cleansing
the CC with mercurial scimitar and
flashing back behind his team
Eero the attack speed buff it kites back
6,000 help on the elder graph boys
alright so not gonna land arrow
flashback way to stay alive but he's
gonna stay a safety both of cats Akbar
now buying time in the front like young
in the front lines as well here gonna be
attacked the shield is going to ball
[ __ ] one is gone shockwave on everything
here's the website country from
wai-keung and the rest of TL curtain of
fog over it's only Laura left the Lyon
Phoenix one Jew win the team fight
because of their positioning and low HP
T L couldn't follow up on the glacial
fissure which led to Phoenix won
decimating their tanks coming in at
number four is SKT setting up an
impeccable teamfight in Game three of
the 2017 midseason Invitational finals
taking on g2 Bank sets up a wall of
traps that forced the enemy towards the
bottom side of the mid lane while peanut
positioned himself at the top of the
lane drawing g2 s frontline towards him
with all of their carries on the bottom
side of the lane wolf flashes to the
wall hits a three man grasping route and
follows it up with a stranglethorn
they've got both of them and now both
the leaders are coming towards the big
lane
there's the black all over the time now
I'm gonna find three with the old buddy
11400 for the trade only unsupportive
descent not going to make it much longer
as well the chase is it look is this
beautiful
with all the teamfight threats held down
SKT take over this fight and ace g2 on
their way to defending their MSI title
at number three is a play from the
fabled telecom wars that's unlike any
other on our list as it features a
number of 200 IQ decisions following a
picture-perfect teamfight SKT had to
decide where to send their players KT
super minions were beginning to siege
their Nexus turrets the Baron was up and
they had a large wave pushing Katie's
mid lane inhibitor turret the team
tasked wolf and hooni with defending
their Nexus while the rest of SKT went
to push mid hooni then teleported to the
last surviving minion to help keep s
Katie's push alive at the cost of both
Nexus turrets share comes down blankets
locked up Aaron
quite low he used the collateral damage
to come to half the head of the pit he's
not there in time but fine time
something by Annie goes for try to look
for who needed to be coming through spam
big jump for it motto goes into the coop
plumps up light from the glacial fissure
they come up with a kill Kuti the
guardian angel just one hit going down
to the devourer is there from wolfy
people I'm a big ramp for it on a bakery
up straight into the death mark on top
a little bit of family still relatively
healthy on the Dragons Vonnegut's
pompous GA then 25 dank throwing up the
curtain call for some damage buddy think
the papers from the shot glass and
Alexis canceled the rest of it
immediately
she gave a kidney to enough it looks
like know will not be able to death
firing away but can't get it scores here
finish it off the answer is it proved to
be worth it as SK team managed to secure
baron and win a five before fight under
their exposed nexus to secure the win to
come out on top
they win the first telecom war a spring
2017 our number to play sees SKT against
the ropes in Game two of their
semi-final match up against the rocks
tigers rocks look to close the game out
with prey and gorillas exceptional
pushing ability and managed to take the
top inhibitor while peanut bought them
time in the bot lane once they had
cracked the base prey delivered an
insane cross map arrow that stopped
Dukes teleport and sealed the game
much more can be done
the minions are gone
FS Katie's return to base staggered and
smeb teleporting in rocks trio at all
but secured the win
Jorge Preah pushed back yet again
coming in at the coveted number one spot
is a fanatic squad that looked all but
finished against SK gaming at IEM
katowice 2013 they had super minions
knocking on their nexuses door and had
just lost a teamfight in SK space that
appeared to be the finishing blow
but expec a had other plans after
escaping the fight with his life the
legendary mid laner hidden the topside
jungle waiting for sk to enter his base
once they did he teleported back to
eske's base and the rest quite literally
his history
is it
[Applause]
[Applause]
well guys I don't know about you but I
feel smarter already
but if any of you brainiacs do disagree
with our top 10 list well let me know in
the comments and I'll see you next week
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
you